[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 28 décembre
voici les titres de cette édition pas de
couvre-feu la nuit de la saint sylvestre
et ni de rentrée scolaire décalé mais
des nouvelles mesures qui concernent les
bars et salles de concerts un délai pour
la dose de rappel vaccinal réduit ou
encore un renforcement du télétravail le
gouvernement a fait ces dernières
annonces ce lundi pour contrer la
propagation du colis 19 que retenir et
quelles sont les réactions le point à
suivre ce beau pays qui est le mien
voici le titre du dernier livre de carlo
livre à paraître prochainement le maire
de poissy entend redonner le goût de la
france l'est lui dédicacer son ouvrage
il ya quelques jours dans une librairie
pisciacaise et puis malgré la crise
sanitaire se sont tout de même toujours
les vacances scolaires à guyancourt la
ville a installé une patinoire éphémère
au pavillon waldeck rousseau elle est
ouverte jusqu'à vendredi
hier le premier ministre jean castex a
donc donné une conférence de presse aux
côtés d'olivier ferrand ministre de la
santé l'objectif mettre en place des
mesures pour freiner la propagation
rapide du variant omicron et l'explosion
du nombre de contaminations quotidiano
qu'ovide 19 concerts assis télétravail
ou encore rentrée des classes non
décaler les réactions des acteurs
yvelinois ces annonces collectées par
justine brasier et céline charles la
tendance sur 7 jours glissants est
aujourd'hui à plus de 70 me le cas le
taux d'un thunder incidence nationale
est ainsi supérieur à 700 soit au plus
haut depuis le début de la crise face à
la flambée des contaminations en france
le gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures ce lundi 27 décembre plusieurs
seront effectives pour trois semaines
boire debout sera interdite dans les
bars et les restaurants pour les
rassemblements la jauge sera limitée à
2000 personnes en intérieur 5000 en
extérieur les concerts debout seront
également interdits un nouveau coup dur
pour le monde du spectacle reste avec le
bas sanitaire soit ça la distance le jet
et puis là bas au dessus il ya l'aspect
artistique c'est pas évident d'avoir des
gens qui sont
si alors qu'ils ont un petit goût et
l'autre c'est là qu'on va pouvoir faire
plaisir à moins de monde ya vu une
reprise fragile
c'est vrai qu'ils arrivent exciter le
public revenait et l'a à nouveau c'est
difficile pour nous c'est vrai c'est
également le grand retour du télétravail
il est de nouveau rendu obligatoire
quand il est possible trois jours
minimum par semaine le télétravail n'est
ne s'impose pas il se prépare et il
s'organise en fonction des situations et
des contraintes de chaque entreprise il
aurait fallu que l'on trouve pas que le
gouvernement se rapproche de nous pour
qu'on puisse d'abord faire un retour
d'expérience et leur dire ce qui marche
ce qui marche pas et surtout surtout
leur dire de la façon dont il faut agir
pour limiter au maximum le contact
dont milieu professionnel parmi les
mesures non retenu la saint sylvestre se
fera son couvre feu même constat pour la
rentrée des classes qui ne sera pas
décaler les élèves retrouveront bien les
salles de cours le 3 janvier prochain
c'est important pour les enfants de
venir à l'école maintenant ce qui serait
au moins tout aussi important c'est de
considérer qu' on est dans un mode pour
être poli dégradée dans l'enseignement
mais c'est pas le point de vue de
monsieur blanc caire qui continuent à
vouloir imposer des réformes à mettre en
place la veille pour le lendemain
qui que les écoles n'ont absolument plus
la capacité de suivre étant donné déjà
la très grande difficulté à assurer la
présence de tous les enfants et de tous
les personnels enfin autre annonce
majeure à retenir le délai pour la dose
de rappel est réduit il passe à trois
mois après la dernière injection du
vaccin
est avec moi par visio conférence pour
parler de ces annonces le professeur
djillali annane bonsoir bonsoir nous est
le doyen de l'ufr simone veil santé de
l'université versailles saint quentin
également chef du service de réanimation
de l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches
dans le 92 alors parmi les mesures on
viens de l'entendre le retour des jauges
le renforcement du télétravail le délai
aussi réduit à trois mois pour la dose
de rappel vaccinal le port du masque à
l'extérieur dans les centres-villes même
si cette mesure reste à la discrétion
des préfets en lien avec les maires mais
pas de couvre feu pour la nuit de la
saint sylvestre et ni de rentrée
scolaire décalé comme le demandaient
certains épidémiologistes
les mesures sont elles suffisantes pour
casser les chaînes de contamination
écoutez c'est difficile à dire a priori
d'un point de vue médical et
scientifique
ces mesures seraient insuffisantes
compte tenu de la contagiosité du
marieur omicron et compte tenu du fait
que nous sommes actuellement
subissons actuellement encore la vague
liés aux pariant delta avec un niveau de
contamination très élevé et donc une
certaine façon de la vague ou mikron va
venir se rajouter à la vague delta est
donc tout ça laisse entrevoir des
intentions sur le système de santé sur
nos collègues en ville mais aussi sur
l'hôpital qui risque de dépasser nos
capacités dans le courant du mois de
janvier très vraisemblablement et les
mesures qui ont été annoncées jusqu'à
présent le risque de ne pas être
suffisante pour
amortir la double vague
d'ailleurs des étapes plus ailleurs
omicron jeunes salon sucre mais
justement pour amortir cette double et
bagues on parle tout de même de 2000
contamination au par jour dans les
yvelines pour éviter aussi un
encombrement des hôpitaux vous en
parliez une mesure comme la rentrée
scolaire décalé serait plus efficace à
vos yeux ça aurait été plus efficace de
prendre une telle mesure il ya deux
raisons pour lesquelles cette mesure est
importante à prendre la première c'est
que nombre des contaminations et nombre
de clusters son parti des écoles
actuellement sommes en période de congés
scolaires donc ce phénomène s'est
atténuée et ne contribue peut
aujourd'hui à la propagation du virus
donc la rentrée scolaire le 3 janvier
risque d'être assez domaine catalyseur
de la propagation du virus puisque les
enfants de moins de 11 ans ne sont pas
encore majoritairement vaccinait le
virus circule de façon très importante
chez les enfants notamment le bailleur
omicron pour des raisons liées aux
mutations porté par le parce variant
d'une part et donc on va avoir dans
cette accélération de la propagation de
les russes à l'occasion de la rentrée
scolaire et puis les nouvelles qui nous
viennent des états unis en particulier
mais qu'on avait déjà d'afrique du sud
semble suggérer qu'avec omicron il y à
un risque plus élevé pour les enfants de
faire des formes symptomatiques voire
d'être hospitalisé y compris pour des
enfants qui n'ont pas de fragilité
particulière et ça ce serait encore une
fois quelque chose d'inédit depuis le
début de la pandémie et bien évidemment
pour le coup
les six l'école l'école risque de ne
plus être un sanctuaire puisque mise de
la santé a souhaité parler de
sanctuariser l'école à sanctuaire c'est
un lieu sûr aujourd'hui avec le vario
mikron n'avons pas la certitude que
l'école reste un lieu sûr pour les
enfants et pour nos enfants nés avec une
précision du ministre de l'éducation
nationale 1 pour qu'un enfant qui a été
positif reviennent au sein de la classe
il faut qu'ils présentent désormais
elles deux tests négatifs alors dans les
yvelines en cette période de fêtes on
dénombre en moyenne une vingtaine
d'entrées quotidiano à l'hôpital quatre
en soins critiques elle est là la
situation dans votre service
actuellement à l'hôpital de garches qui
est lui un situé dans le département
voisin des hauts de seine notre service
est sous tension comme la plupart des
services de réanimation de la région ile
de france c'est que nous sommes complets
et le moindre lee qui se libèrent et
pourvus dans l'heure qui suit avec
souvent plusieurs sur les citations pour
un 10 disponible donc on voit qu'on est
à saturation principalement du fait de
la coop 19 mai vous le disiez tout à
l'heure c'est une situation qui pourrait
même et bien aller en empirant quel est
le profil justement des personnes qui
développent des formes graves de collier
de 19 est-ce qu'il s'agit principalement
de personnes non vaccinées
effectivement les personnes non
vaccinées reste indiscutablement les
principales personnes à risque de faire
des formes peu sévères et représentent
les principales personnes que nous
hospitalisation nous pardon que nous
hospitalise on dans nos services il ya
aussi malheureusement des personnes qui
sont vaccinées soit qu'elles n'ont pas
encore eu l'or troisième injection c'est
aujourd'hui que la vaccination complète
c'est après trois doses et puis il ya
des personnes qui malheureusement ou une
vaccination complète mais souffrent de
maladies sous jacentes cancer par
exemple ou d'autres maladies qui diminue
leur défense qui du coup n'arrive pas à
se protéger
malgré la vaccination de formes sévères
ça veut dire que la vaccination reste un
maillon essentiel on l'a compris dans
cette lutte contre le coc u19 mais ce
n'était pas la seule solution en tout
cas si elle n'est pas couplé avec
d'autres mesures ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure il faut la coupler avec
d'autres mesures pour que ce soit
efficace
absolument ça fait partie des
fondamentaux que nous avons appris
depuis deux ans il n'y a absolument
aucune mesure qui à elles seules
permettent de mettre fin à une vague et
encore moins de mettre fin à la pandémie
c'est bien un ensemble de mesures qui
comprend obligatoirement la vaccination
et les gestes barrière qui peuvent
permettre de contrôler l'épidémie virale
est aujourd'hui côté ges de barrières
bien malheureusement on est on est pas
au haut niveau optimal très clairement
et du côté de la vaccination bat on
n'est qu'à 50 % finalement de personnes
qui sont à trois injections donc là
encore on peut dire qu'on a un retard à
combler en termes de lavaur tarn de
vaccination et des mesures plus
contraignantes à prendre en carte de
gestes barrières
merci professeur diana d'avoir est avec
nous
jean prix je le rappelle doyen de l'ufr
simone veil santé l'université
versailles saint quentin également chef
du service de réanimation de l'hôpital
raymond poincaré dans le 92
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité le maire de
poissy persiste et signe il veut tu un
déménagement de la prison centrale karl
olive a publié un communiqué hier lundi
où il réaffirme sa position sur ce
dossier que l'élu défend depuis 2014 une
publication seulement trois jours après
l'incendié survenu sur place dans la
nuit de noël un détenu a mis le feu à sa
cellule causant d'importants dégagements
de fumée l'individu est intoxiqué comme
deux agents pénitentiaires les
prisonniers avaient dû être transféré
dans une autre aile du bâtiment et 50
pompiers ont été mobilisés autre
incident qui vient s'ajouter à celui de
mars 2019 une partie du mur d'enceinte
du lieu s'était effondré les travaux de
réfection devraient débuter cette année
et l'année prochaine plutôt en 2022 la
ville indique chercher activement un
terrain pour accueillir une nouvelle
prison le maire a été reçu il ya
quelques mois déjà par le ministre de la
justice karl olive qui a écrit un
nouveau livre ce beau pays qui est le
mien c'est son titre entend insuffler un
vent d'optimisme aux français qui
auraient perdu espoir en leur pays elle
et lui étaient présents il ya quelques
jours à la librairie du pain serait à
poissy pour une séance de dédicaces
mathier de francs quand en plein coeur
de la crise sanitaire et à quelques mois
de l'élection présidentielle le maire de
poissy sort un nouveau livre intitulé ce
beau pays qu'est le mien car le livre
propose des pistes de solution pour
redonner aux français qu'ils ont perdu
le goût de leur pays moi je pense que
ici en france on est un pays comme le
disent et sylvain tesson un paradis
peuplé de gens qui se croient en enfer
et je veux montrer aux français qu' il
ya tellement de choses qui nous
rassemblent à côté de tout ce qui peut
nous diviser le maire des pisciacais
étaient présents le 21 décembre dans la
librairie du pain frais pour dédicacer
son livre en avant-première moi je suis
ravi d'être ici puis je suis à l'enfant
de poissy donc ça fait plaisir de devoir
les pisciacais et les pisciacais qui
parfois bon vu grandir et ils étaient
nombreux au rendez vous pour pouvoir
rencontrer le maire les essais de
rencontrer
monsieur olives en fait que j'apprécie
bien son pragmatisme en fait au
quotidien dans les sujets qu'ils
traitent dans sa ville en fête ça
m'intéresse de voir les solutions qu'il
a apporté
on a répondu municipal et peut-être
nationale c'est beau pays qui est le
mien paraîtra messi janvier on va
chausser à présent les patins à glace
dans ce journal jusqu'au 31 décembre la
ville de guyancourt propose une
patinoire éphémère c'est la troisième
fois au pavillon waldeck-rousseau petits
et grands peuvent y profiter des
vacances scolaires le reportage de
céline chat au milieu de toutes les
festivités de noël la magie s'installe
également au pavillon pierre waldeck
rousseau à guyancourt une patinoire
éphémère s'y est implanté samedi 18
décembre pour une douzaine de jours
pour la cour le lac d'affaires en 2020
elle plaît à voir que dans la nouvelle
est vacant couleur
dit que j'avais fait était villa est
dernier avec les jeunes
[Musique]
parents et enfants peuvent venir
s'adonner aux joies de la glisse les
plus petits ont à leur disposition des
supports de patinage en forme d'ourson
deux pingouins des animateurs
périscolaire sont également présents sur
la piste on assure la sécurité
et puis aussi on anime un petit peu au
travers de des différentes races a fait
une petite chorégraphie ça fait des
petits jeux avec les enfants mais aussi
les adultes n'ont pas de parents des
grands-parents beaucoup de
grands-parents
maintenant très intéressante pour eux
parce que ça permet aux
enfants durant les vacances scolaires
ludique mais aussi écologique la
patinoire n'utilise pas de glace mais un
terrain synthétique qui assure le même
confort de glisse tout en étant beaucoup
moins coûteux en énergie
les enfants ils prennent ils passent du
bon temps il s'amusait en général en
tout cas il ya deux ans ils s'amusaient
là sur la piste ils ressortent avec le
sourire une soirée spéciale jeunes à
partir de 15 ans est également prévue le
30 décembre de 19h à 21h
avant de vous laisser cette disparition
celle de grichka bogdanov qui s'est
éteint ce mardi à 28 décembre
paisiblement pour rejoindre les étoiles
a écrit sa famille dans un communiqué il
était l'un des deux jumeaux célèbre
bogdanov star des années 1980 avec
l'émission temps x sur tf1 connu
également pour leur transformation
physique atypique et leurs ouvrages
scientifiques controversé grichka son
frère igor était venu en 2018 à l'ugc
skywest à montigny-le-bretonneux invités
de saint quentin le festival du film
documentaire de saint quentin en
yvelines porté par tv 78 et cette
émission spéciale temps x1 retransmise à
l'époque sur notre antenne vous sera
proposé ce mardi soir à 20h une
rediffusion qui vous sera proposé donc à
20h sur tv 78 voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité
rendez vous demain mercredi pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]